[Music]
all right recently Chinese media was
reporting that an anonymous online
shopper paid 40 million yuan which is
about 5.6 million dollars for his very
own rocket lunch and he won this on the
shop or like he bought this on the
shopping platform Taobao
Chinese Chinese leading online shopping
platform Rockets where's he - this was
like offered like a service offered
online where it's like hey you can want
to buy some rocket you could pay for
anything you can paint the rocket
whatever you want you could come visit
the launch site you can like be here and
like control it and he doesn't get a
ride in it no dad this is like a fun
charity event yeah pretty much
however you want personalize it amazing
in China I will bake it on Danny as dick
yeah yeah that's China
there you go only painted our flag red
or yellow where you commanding whatever
you want it just to be these two colors
and look like this
scale of the flag don't feel me variety
yeah but here's so so many choices when
it was up for sale
can you read any of these but we didn't
say imma see SpaceX rocket one of them
says fast yeah one of them says fire oh
you're serious
what why the guy want that well so it's
anonymous so we don't know who pay for
this but the rocket launch will be held
in Wuhan whoohoo so it seems like a lot
of people should make it a bad
if they have to paint it something just
suggestion you don't have to choose mice
very good beans there yes yes the
library were speculating that this is
all like a stunt to pretty much reap
remote Wuhan in a more positive light so
not that bad idea yeah that wouldn't
work maybe Batman so many conspiracies
about that rock and now I'm gonna be
like they're shooting bucket melona in
the air oh yeah man there's just a lot
of [ __ ] going on with the conspiracy
side of things though because they're
supposed to be like a chemical plant
near that area - or like they're doing
like some kind of chemical engineering
stuff when this whole thing started
happening did they arrest like to
Harvard teachers you did yeah they
arrest like to Harvard teachers for for
working with the Chinese government
they're getting paid in independently
and they're reporting all everything
that they're doing back to China and
they figured them out and they're like
FBI came in all about the corner virus -
so it was like we're like and then they
never talked about it again and they
just like there's just a lot of weird
interesting things that are going down
like that - like I read some [ __ ] about
US soldiers we're out there - and then
they got admitted to a hospital and they
were sick they were out there because of
they were taking I was like I just
briefly read it really quick but it was
basically you're a headline reader yeah
yeah it was just like two soldiers went
out and they were in that area for
personal or whatever reasons I don't
know but they were admitted into a
hospital with a sickness I know there's
so many conspiracy the recent one that I
heard that I was like well that's a
different approach is that this is the
beginning of the rapture and everyone
that's dying from the Rona's non Jesus
believer no no is that they are going to
heaven they're they're leaving they're
leaving earth so that once the rapture
starts they're gonna give us flu shots
and that's gonna be the mark of the
devil and that's why there's so many
Italians dying so we can't go there
Catholics yeah Chinese Catholics do then
or Chinese Christians if that was true
God sucks like a really bad disease of
this [ __ ] alright you feel sad and
alone and all I could it be like the
movies where you just like I send it to
heaven you know if you have the power
fimo all right a guy eat a bat and then
now he'll go to have it I never liked
looking at you there's so many weird
conspiracies though but it's so hard
because everything is still in
development it's kind of like when 9/11
happened or just even during the
recession no one really knew what caused
it until later they investigated and
they're like oh it was the [ __ ]
stupid ass mortgages like every like 20s
like 1920s 18 20 and 17 20s it's been a
plague really every 20 years every day a
hundred years every 20 years after the
new century
Bill Gates theory yeah they said that he
released it because he did a TED talk
about pandemics and how we have we have
to really prepare for one and they're
saying that he has the was it the
antibody or the vaccine because they and
he released it into the public so you
can make a sload of money so many
conspiracy it's to evil genius but what
I believe is that we were long overdue
for one anyway apparently 800 years yeah
every hundred years if you look back at
when all the other pandemics happen it
was a hundred years like last year
nineteen twenties was a Spanish flu
1820s was like I'm surprised we don't
have one more frequently because of how
connected we are worldwide because
there's a lot of things like [ __ ]
dengue fever and [ __ ] that's going down
and it's affecting millions of people
but it gets no what's the word like
publicity like we're not worried of it
because most of these diseases are like
in Africa or important countries that
affect us yeah how it affects us we're
not gonna really exactly because when
this whole [ __ ] was going down in China
everyone would was like not even taking
it seriously
well AIDS is still considered like ones
like the viruses they just haven't have
fun a case but that's only spread
through that time a sexual transmitted
yeah
true have you guys seen that meme uh
Magic Johnson so he's walking and then
he has the the facemask and then in the
edit the text list oh now you care cuz
ya HIV and AIDS and he didn't have any
protection the whole time but all of a
sudden he cares about protection now you
can get that yeah seems like every
decade according to this timeline of
history of pandemics
well like pandemics in terms of like
something becomes a pandemic but not to
the scale of like the 1918 flu or
something so how many people died like
hiv/aids is upend emic well we had
several do a lot of things since
pandemic since the Spanish we had a lot
since Spanish flu we had SARS MERS MERS
what the cross is borders it's a
pandemic if it's yeah cross but I don't
know for me I still consider it Asia as
one continent group so it's still
epidemic I don't know but then I don't
know I think it depends on I forgot how
it becomes a pandemic but a pandemic is
when it spreads across borders without
just people going everywhere when it
starts popping up in places where there
weren't people traveling from that area
that's when it's like okay that's what
like this when they don't like know who
it is like in a direct contact kind of
way right Dan the Spanish flu is 40 to
50 million people
dude it was it's crazy man hiv/aids is
25 to 35 million oh my gosh does that
many people hate it's mostly in Africa
though starting from 1981 to present
time so there's not a whole span if the
Spanish would happen now though it
wouldn't be as bad because we have much
better medicine at the time then when
what we had back then believed them
[ __ ] bloodletting is [ __ ] yeah stupid
asses so in the vaccine for this thing
that we have right now we don't have
about there's no vaccine that's why it
it takes like a year to make but no one
knows that if that would be a vaccine
because it's mutating so fast they are
working on
here about like scientists working on
one vaccine to get them all get all the
flus and any mutation really yeah
they're working on like a power yeah
that's hard I mean maybe I don't think
you get to see how it is but it's like
there's things that pop up all the time
at night they're mutes I mean you can
never get sick from anything know from
flu-like specifically like the flu you
know the flu changes like yeah this
would be offer all flus or for all
diseases oh this is gonna be hard cuz
depending on which animal you're
friendly with you dog flu or the cow
food you scabby friends with this animal
they live in the animals here and it's
been so it starts off with like rats
please bacteria don't like a plague a
lot of them mosquitoes will vary via
Norrish origins like birds
pigs chimpanzees pigs bats what are
civet man these animals are dirt camels
sick-ass Hannibal Burres
came from beds and camels the [ __ ] is
eating the camel saying even from the
corona corona virus whatever bleep it's
a it started in a bat but then it jumped
to what was it anteater or something and
then I went to humans
so what are you viruses for a long time
that's why I like AI special on these
balls they have it and everything and
it's like what we have is like a like a
variation of it but like I think it's
who who monitors all these things but
they don't it doesn't become bad until
it it's able to jump from animal to
human oh yeah they did see so we're here
it says possibly penguins and penguins
are an African and Asian mammal that has
a body covered with horny overlapping
scales a small head with an elongated
snout a long sticky tongue for catching
ants and termites sounds like an
anteater basically an anteater also
called a steely ant either wonderful but
I saw this dick all the time like the
[ __ ] I don't think they even think when
they get it they just kind of get it
kinda like all the young people get into
here you know let's it's weird because
it's like the same thing like how humans
they just have things where it's like if
I go to an indigenous tribe oh yeah that
could bring things that
are I'm fine with because they're so
isolated I built the immunity up it from
being like a dirty-ass european coming
into the [ __ ] lead of a man yeah yeah
same [ __ ] bring a smallpox that's true
kinds of diseases one from the animal
because animals have a lot more and
maybe because animals can don't take
showers yeah anything that's like not in
the same society right so like the bats
are separate that's what we should love
Allah zation is everyone build the
immunities for everything just take well
that that takes by doing all the bats I
have new diseases come up and viruses
and [ __ ] like it's just never-ending you
know everybody's so sick man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]